this chapter the story of Thomas
Alva Edison let there be light
the miracle of glittering modern cities of
shining electric lights the world owes this
and more to Thomas Edison the employment of
the first practical incandescent lamp which
I invented was the carbonized cotton thread in
the search for a better filament i carbonized
everything likely carbonized paper horseshoe
lamps were used in the first public demonstration
of the electric Matic system in Menlo Park on
December 31st 1879 this is a replica of the one
of the first copper flood lamps said Edison of
his invention of the phonograph first words I
spoke in the original phonograph a little feats
of practical poetry mary had a little lamb its
fleece was white as snow and everywhere
that mary went the lamb was sure to go
the Edison story began in the little
house in Milan Ohio the boys inventive
genius showed early he had a laboratory
in the cellar when he was 10 years old
during the Civil War when he was 15 Edison was
a newsboy in the railroad the war reached into
every town and home folks waited daily at the
railroad station for Tom and the train to come
in bringing news of the fighting peace came and
telegraph lines began spreading across the land
fascinated by the new invention Edison went to
work putting up telegraph lines he was 17 years
old leaving home he worked for four years
as a telegraph operator in various Midwest
cities and tinkered with the instruments to
improve them in 1869 Edison came to New York
City panelists looking for a job it was a time
of hardship then he invented a stock ticker the
forerunner the ticker machines used in modern
Stock Exchange's the invention netted Edison
$40,000 he was comparatively wealthy and in love
Mary Stilwell became his wife at Menlo Park New
Jersey he embarked on his career as a full-fledged
inventor was a period of tremendous creative
activity one of its highlights was the invention
of the first talking machine the phonograph was an
international sensation it brought Edison
Fame and a nickname Wizard of Menlo Park
every mechanical problem was a challenge
Edison's improvements made the typewriter a
practical writing machine the telephone was
invented simultaneously by Edison and Bell
now you tackle the greatest challenge of all the
electric light previous research you felt had been
on the wrong track you sketched incandescent lamps
experimented with them trying to find a filament
that would burn brightly and have long life
thousands of materials were tried and rejected
your co-workers gave up hope stubbornly you went
on and after a year of superhuman labor success
you announced a daring project to bring electric
light to the downtown district of New York
all the intricate machinery of
the first power station had to
be invented and built by you there were
no precedents but finally everything
was ready for the turning of the
main switch on the control board
electric street lamps burning for the first time
in history the age of electricity had arrived
soon horse-drawn trolley cars disappeared
in their place electric trolleys invented
by Edison electric lines carried power to city
in rural homes evil-smelling gas lamps with a
flip of the switch were abolished the invention
of the electric light the harnessing of electric
power had changed the face of the earth but
for Thomas Edison it was only the beginning
now it was 1917 thirty years had passed since
the invention of the electric lamp edison had
moved his laboratory to West Orange New Jersey he
was 70 years old but as active as ever recovering
from the loss of his first wife he had remarried
happily the flow of inventions had continued
with hardly a pause his library contained the
finest private collection of scientific books
in existence there Edison turned to a variety
of scientific problems his theories were tested
in the laboratory the most complete private
laboratory in the world inventions had brought
Edison great wealth but to him money was only
the means to an end he spent millions of dollars
without a second thought and scientific
research and the results were astonishing
experimenting he developed a fluoroscope and
gave it to the public without profit he spent
years creating a satisfactory storage battery
and a system of shipped to shore a wireless
telegraphy the forerunner of radio his deafness
the result of a boyhood injury grew worse with
the ears but no handicap could impede his genius
he devised machinery to improve the mixing of
cement and the mining of iron ore then with no
previous experience in photography he invented
the first motion picture camera his motion picture
studio was the first in the world here the world's
first movies were made some of them talkies
anticipating Hollywood by many years Edison
was the world's first movie fan he was also by now
the world's greatest inventor in recognition he
received the Congressional Medal of Honor from
secretary of the Treasury Andrew Mellon nearly
50 years had passed since the first electric lamp
was lighted you were 81 years old now but still as
active as ever with your old friends naturalist
John burrows and Henry Ford you went on camping
trips gray-haired giants of Industry and science
all three of you enjoyed competing in tests of
strength for you after years of unending work
those camping trips with Ford and Burroughs were
well-earned and welcome relaxation in old age you
had learned how to play but it was always good to
get back to the laboratory the main thing in your
life was science you made only one concession to
the advancing years winters were spent on your
estate at Fort Myers Florida there you worked
in a fine laboratory near your home Henry Ford had
pointed out that the rubber needed for automobiles
was imported from abroad in case of war the
supply might be cut off Ford urged you to find
a homegrown substitute for the foreign rubber
plant it was your latest project and your last
no let-up the day I'll retire
you said will be the day before
I die and you expected to live to be a hundred
the search for a rubbish substitute went on
tirelessly near the laboratory you raised
plants of all kinds testing them for rubber
content you discovered more than 600 American
plants containing rubber the best you found
was native goldenrod crossbreeding goldenrod
selectively you produced varieties
that were rich in rubber content
a few years more you promised and
the problem of rubber would be solved
timeout from research on your 84th birthday
to meet with the reporters what do you think
of the Einstein theory I don't see anything of
Einstein's theory because I can't understand it
what do you think of the sound pictures to the
of today what I think of the talking picture
yeah well I don't know I never heard them how does
it feel to be 84 years old well it sounds really
fun the only four years of age if you don't
have anything the matter with you well I have
a little trouble dial dead but that's because
I'm getting old well I bet a lot of ginger yep
a few months later the old man passed
away and although the rubber project
was never finished he left a stupendous heritage
the great cities will forever bear his mark
in subways and skyscrapers his genius is in
the modern phonograph and in such common
objects as the electric lights Edison made
possible radio and television broadcasting the
electric train was his creation and improved
concrete for bridges modern communications
his gift and great dams transforming water
power into electricity power stations sending
electricity to turn the wheels of Industry
without Edison it would have been impossible
let there be light the greatest miracle is
perhaps that so much of modern living came
from the brain of one man Thomas Alva Edison